hi i'm at ken let's software developer
with my space i'm here to show you the
application we developed for the android
platform first we'll go to the homepage
the app features the core social
networking functions of myspace
including searching and add friends
commenting on photos blogs and profiles
messaging and viewing and uploading
photos first full view our friend status
next I'll update mine
next we'll upload a photo to myspace I'm
accessing the phone's library right here
choosing a photo end up letting it to
myspace we can view the uploaded photo
in its album right here and there we go
we're excited about the Android platform
and we develop this application to take
advantage of the rich device
capabilities it presents to us we've
previously developed applications for
other mobile platforms and Android was a
logical next step our application began
as a port of our iPhone app we're able
to use this stuff to start out using the
same assets we consume the same soap web
services and we're able to take the XML
layout files from that application and
perform accessibility transforms on them
to generate the initial layout for this
application we used apache access to
generate stubs from the wsdl files and
we use case up to to perform the soap
network calls